.
>> Will: GIVING UP ON TELLING
YOU THE BORDER IS SECURE.
IN CHICAGO, THE CRIME CRISIS
ABSOLUTELY OUT OF CONTROL.
THE LATEST NEWS THERE IS YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE A HARDER TIME
UNDERSTANDING HEARING ABOUT IT.
THE LATEST MOVE IN CHICAGO IS
THAT THE CITY IS LOOKING TO BAN
OR STOP THE ABILITY OF THE MEDIA
AND CITIZENRY TO HEAR THE POLICE
SCANNER.
POLICE AND FIRE SCANNERS BLOCK
IS THAT SIGNAL.
>> Steve: THEY ARE GOING TO
START ENCRYPTING IT.
EVERY NEWSROOM I HAVE EVER
WORKED IN OVER THERE AT THE
ASSIGNMENT DESK.
THE DISPATCHER HAS A POLICE
SCANNER SO HE CAN HEAR WHEN
THERE IS A CHEMICAL STILL SPILL
OR A HOSTAGE SITUATION.
>> Ainsley: TRAFFIC CONGESTION.
>> Steve: SOMETHING OF INTEREST
TO THE PEOPLE SO THAT WE CAN GET
THE WORD OUT HEY, AVOID THIS
INTERSECTION BECAUSE THERE IS A
CHEMICAL SPILL OR THERE IS AN
ACTIVE SHOOTER OR STUFF LIKE
THAT.
WHAT THEY'RE DOING IS
ESSENTIALLY GOING TO ENCRYPT ALL
THE CHANNELS AND ONLY FOR
DECADES NEWS DEPARTMENTS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE LISTENED
TO THAT SO THEY KNOW WHERE TO
SEND THE CREWS.
IN CHICAGO, WHEN WE SEND CREWS
TO THE NEWS AND THERE IS
BREAKING NEWS, BAD NEWS ALL
OVER, IT'S MAKING CHICAGO LOOK
BAD.
SO THE QUESTION IS, IS LORI
LIGHTFOOT ENCRYPTING THE POLICE
SCANNERS SO THE NEWS MEDIA IN
CHICAGO CAN'T REPORT THE NEWS?
IT KIND OF LOOKS LIKE IT.
AND THAT'S WHY A WHOLE BUNCH OF
NEWS OUTFITS OUT THERE HAVE SENT
LETTERS TO THE MAYOR SHE WILL
NOT BUDGE.
>> YOU WALK INTO ANY NEWSROOM,
LOCAL NEWSROOM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND YOU WILL SEE THE
ASSIGNMENT DESK AND ALL THE
REPORTERS ARE SITTING IN THE
NEWSROOM.
WE ALL HAD CUBICLES, OUR DESKS
WERE FACING EACH OTHER SO WE
COULD SEE EACH OTHER AND ALWAYS
HEAR WHAT WAS GOING ON.
SHORT ACROSS THE NEWSROOM SAYING
THIS IS JUST BREAKING GET ON THE
SET WE HAVE GOT TO REPORT.
THIS THERE IS A SHOOTING AT THE
SCHOOL OR A BUS THAT'S
OVERTURNED OR WHATEVER IT MIGHT
BE IN LOCAL NEWS A AND YOU CAN
HEAR THOSE SCANNERS UP AT THE
ASSIGNMENT DESK.
THEY ARE GETTING THE NEWS IN
REALTIME SO WE CAN REPORT IT TO
YOU.
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IT EFFECTS YOU
AND YOUR FAMILY.
THERE IS A LETTER TO THE FOX 32
READERS IN CHICAGO AND IT TALKS
ABOUT HOW THIS IS GOING TO
IMPACT OUR ABILITY TO PROVIDE
TIMELY, ACCURATE, POTENTIALLY
LIFE-SAVING NEWS TO YOU.
THEY SAID THERE WAS A SHOOTING
AT A COURTHOUSE THERE.
THE PERPETRATOR FIRED MORE THAN
40 SHOTS IN EXPRESSWAY.
THE CITY OF CHICAGO PREVENTED
FROM YOU KNOWING ABOUT THIS
DANGEROUS INCIDENT BY BLOCKING
ALL OF OUR LIVE SCANNER
TRANSMISSIONS.
ALSO ANOTHER GUY WITH A RIFLE
WALKING DOWN THE STREET AT WEST
POOLMAN NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND CHICAGO POLICE SAID WE --
THEY SAID WE ARE NOT ABLE TO
ALERT THE PUBLIC WHAT IS HANG.
ALSO AROUND DINNERTIME PEOPLE
RETURNING HOME FROM WORK AND
CHILDREN RETURNING HOME FROM
SCHOOL.
>> Steve: THAT'S WHAT THE LOCAL
AFFILIATE IN CHICAGO WROTE.
BUT, A COALITION OF MEDIA
OUTFITS WROTE IN PART WE ASK TO
MEET IN PERSON WITH THE CITY TO
FURTHER ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
BUT DESPITE MULTIPLE ATTEMPTS,
MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT FLATLY
REFUSES TO DISCUSS THE MATTER.
IN SHORT, THE MAYOR'S DECISION
TO RESTRICT OUR ACHE SELLS TO
SCANNER CHANNELS WILL HARM OUR
ABILITY TO KEEP YOU, OUR READERS
AND VIEWERS AND LISTENERS SAFE
AND INFORMED.
AND MORE DIFFICULT TO HOLD OUR
GOVERNMENT AND ITS PERSONNEL
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> JUST A COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO ON
THE PROGRAM, WE TALKED TO BILL
KELLY, WILLIAM KELLY, A REPORTER
OUT IN CHICAGO.
HIS PRESS PASS WAS REVOKED BY
THE CITY OF CHICAGO HE IS FAMOUS
FOR ASKING THE MAYOR HARD
QUESTIONS.
PULLING THE PRESS CREDENTIALS
FOR EVERY NEWS OUTFIT.
YOU WILL NOT BE ABLE TO HEAR THE
POLICE SCANNER ANYMORE.
HERE IS WHAT HE TOLD US ABOUT
THE MAYOR ON NOVEMBER 23RD.
>> I WAS ASKING THE OBVIOUS
QUESTIONS.
AND AS SHE LOST HER TEMPER EVERY
SINGLE TIME.
THE VIDEOS WENT VIRAL.
MILLIONS OF COMMENTS, LIKES AND
SHARES.
BUT NOW MAYOR LIGHTFOOT IS IN
RE-ELECTION MODE AND SHE DOESN'T
WANT ANY MORE EMBARRASSING
QUESTIONS TO GO VIRAL, SO SHE
REVOKED MY MEDIA CREDENTIAL.
AND I'M TELLING YOU RIGHT NOW,
STEVE.
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS
CONSTITUTIONAL CRISIS IN THE
CITY OF CHICAGO AND SHE WANTS
TO, YOU KNOW, WIN THIS CASE
AGAINST ME AND THEN EXPAND THIS
ATTACK ON THE FIRST AMENDMENT TO
ALL THE REPORTERS WHO ASK HER
REAL QUESTIONS OR ANY REPORTER
NATIONALLY WHO WOULD DARE TO ASK
A REAL QUESTION OF A POWERFUL
POLITICIAN.
>> Will: LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
COMES TO ELECTIONS OR COVID OR
CRIME IS IF YOU CAN'T CONTROL
REALITY, CAN YOU CONTROL THE
PERCEPTION OF REALITY.
AND WHAT IS HAPPENING IN CHICAGO
NOW, WHAT WE CAN SEE FROM MAYOR
LORI LIGHTFOOT IS SHE IS NOT
GOING TO CONTROL THAT CRIME
CRISIS.
BUT IN AN ATTEMPT TO WIN
RE-ELECTION, SHE IS GOING TO
CONTROL THE MINDS OF CHICAGOANS
AS TO EXACTLY WHAT IS HAPPENING
IN THEIR STATE.
>> Ainsley: A WAY FOR HER TO
CONTROL LAW KNOW AND DON'T KNOW.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW ALL THE CRIME,
THEN YOU ARE IN THE DARK.
AND SHE LOOKS BETTER IF THE
CRIME NUMBERS ARE DOWN OR IF YOU
DON'T -- MEDIA IS NOT ABLE TO
REPO